but I was always getting feedback that
like oh the audition was good but she's
not pretty enough to play the girlfriend
on the other side I've been a part of
some pretty massive failures and I I
just don't really care I really
genuinely like to look for the good in
people it makes me a happier person
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from actress
Kristen Bell and my take on her top ten
rules for success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
when I was auditioning it was always
will learn it's definitely a hustle like
you have to like much like you guys know
you got a as an actor you got to be on
you got to be sending your resume and
your picture to people but I was always
getting feedback that like oh the
audition was good but she's not pretty
enough to play the girlfriend and she's
not holy enough to play the quirky best
friends we just don't have a place for
her and I was like okay and then I don't
you just you just rip it yeah it's
frustrating but it I really made sure
thankfully like I had a good family
members that kept me very grounded and I
just found Michigan you're like
Heartland yeah yeah Michigan and I just
I I don't know I made sure that my feet
never came off the ground and I made
sure that I was doing it because I loved
it like I was like if I wasn't booking
some big movie that I had the chance to
audition to like I would join the
community theater play like I wanted to
be doing it it was always an internal
barometer of self-esteem and I tried to
really commit to that and that's one
thing I really try to commit to with
raising my kids is is always looking for
your self esteem internally and never
externally because then I with the
rejection would feel less because I
wouldn't get cast in a movie but I would
get cast in the community theater
production and I was like great I have a
job did you do your blog with shrimp no
yes now make it say's obsessed with
praise and success and box office and
stuff and I I think for some reason I
was just lucky that I wasn't obsessed
with that stuff because I know a lot of
actors that are and yeah I'm so thankful
that I don't have that gear to like be
on box office mojo in the morning after
a project comes out but on the other
side I've been a part of some pretty
massive failures and I I just don't
really care I mean it's a lover of
course I would want every movie I've
been a part of to make a hundred million
dollars and that would be so great and
everybody would win but I don't let the
success of a project or the lack of the
success of a project which many have not
made
a lot of money take away from the
experience I just think the experience
is so much we are important and I'm I I
strive to stay in that headspace because
it's not natural of course you want all
these things as a greedy human being but
I always remind myself like hey guess
what doesn't matter anything other than
the people you're in the room with I
really genuinely like to look for the
good in people it makes me a happier
person and if someone has a sign on the
side of the road that says I'm hungry
and my family's in the van those are the
only details I know about that person
you know and then they may or may not be
facts but currently I don't know
anything else that may or may not be a
fact so I always start with the face
value and I yeah I really like to give
people the benefit of the doubt because
I also want them to give me the benefit
of the doubt and I really believe in how
you act as sort of your karma I'm not
screwing around where's the bar in the
street
and in our household we live by a
standard kind of love what the AAA
teaching is which I highly recommend it
even for I mean I'm not I don't struggle
with addiction but I love what that
teaches you about looking inward and
about personal responsibility and when
you sort of figure that out everything
else starts to come easier and it's a
commitment in truth to vulnerability
like I think that especially we as women
vulnerability is our superpower and we
don't and I don't know what game like
the world is playing with like the suits
and like the you know wigs with all the
dudes used to wear as judges like I
don't know what game we think we're
playing with like this presentational
buttoned up not human thing but we
believe that like when you if you're
having a fight and you're calling each
other names and then you just stop and
you go that hurt my feelings the fight
stops and that's like it's a huge lesson
for me because I really think all of
these things that we are trying to do if
we just make our circle of human
connection bigger and incorporate more
vulnerability all the sudden things
start to make sense and like our spirit
is nurtured and like we that's what we
do better there I say as women like
we're sitting in this room right now you
know and we're talking and like the
speaker's aren't just talking about like
business and numbers we're talking about
emotions and how to keep our personal
life sane and that's that's our super
power and the more we do that the more
we gather and talk and share the quicker
we're gonna fix all the like whatever is
happening right now the world is in a
bad mood that's the bottom line the
world is in our earth is in a very bad
mood and we have the power through
communication to fix it acknowledging
what we're previously viewed as
weaknesses like our ability to have
maternal instincts and nurture and
communication those are actually our
superpowers my husband says some stupid
joke as he does every
two minutes I come home and I say like
when you said that that actually hurt my
feelings and nobody ever meets you with
anything other than love when you're
vulnerable and that can work in business
and for me it's staying confident that
my like god-given instincts as a woman
are my strengths and they are things
that that move the needle
did you actually pay for that can I ask
you a serious question
but you probably you're doing stuff that
scares you making this choice yeah was
there thought about careers or career
point and this or are you not thinking
that way you're just like no well it
could look like that of like oh she must
have wanted to do something different
but I don't want to do something
different because of my career I want to
do something different because I was
bored last summer I was bored of the
things I was being sent I was bored of
the roles that I had already played and
I didn't want to do anything again and
this project was so unique and so
graphic and so provocative and so unlike
anything I'd done that I very much
wanted to be a part of it because I had
never done anything like this before
I'd really want to do a project where I
don't smile because I know all my
projects like hey again nauseated with
my existence in we always I think which
is a reach out just to get it together
and I read it and I was like oh I don't
know where she would smile and that to
me was like I was like yes I want to be
involved like she's not energetic and
bubbly and all these other things cute
yeah that I usually either gravitate
towards or people gravitate to me saying
like oh Kristen Bell might be this and
it just was such a great opportunity for
me to do something different
[Music]
what now with any busy schedule I think
it's just important to stay grounded and
remember that you're a human being it's
not a machine and it's really important
to wake up in the morning and take a
deep breath and look around at the
people that you love and realize that
that's really the most important thing
and it sounds corny and cliche until you
start to do it every day
and then I've found that my life is so
much more fulfilled because of that I
don't have any friends I'm pretty
isolated at home I have four kids Disney
makes great movies all their movies are
great but this movie in particular yeah
well I don't think anyone can foresee
the the like box office but my craziness
that it hit but I'll tell you when we
were making it there was a part of me
that was going like this is really
special like I've been a part of a lot
of things but this it just felt so
unique and I'm so proud of it because
it's just it's unlike anything they've
ever done and I love the fact that it's
not about romantic love it's about
believing in someone even when they
don't believe in themselves and I just
get so proud when I think that I was a
part of a project that's shown to kids
that you know just tells them like be
who you are be different be quirky and
let it go the difference between a
lawyer and a prostitute prostitutes stop
screwing you and you're dead I'm
involved with a lot of charity work
because the minute I see something that
I feel my heart wants to follow like I
just do it and there's tons of local
stuff that you can do and when you feel
your when you start to feel good about
yourself if you can't stop it it's like
turning on a faucet and you just it just
comes you know like I was really
obsessed with the refugee crisis and so
I called the IRC and I was like how can
we be a host family and so we have had a
couple times these people this family
that just settled from Afghanistan over
to our house and like nobody speaks
English but we like make playdough on
the stove and play with the kids and
like I walk away from those nights going
like oh today I did it like I was good
on earth I'm putting the earth in a
little bit better of a mood I honestly
think I
just put here by mistake in truth I
became much more comfortable as I grew
older and as you let go your desire to
compare yourself to everything and
everyone you realize how unreasonable
that is we are given once you can really
understand we are given an unrealistic
and unattainable idea and representation
of beauty you go oh wait a minute the
whole thing is just a joke and a trick
oh then who cares the worrying about
what other people think of you have you
become so so unimportant also when you
fill your life with wonderful things and
friends and love you don't have taught
you just don't have time to worry about
nonsense that's my favorite shirt don't
ever do it is your baby dance like that
not like that but she does love to dance
and you should get good dancers she's a
pretty decent dancer she points at the
jam box in our living room when she
wants to dance what you have a jam box
in your living room used to roller skate
to your shoulder if you felt like it
you can throw any music to it and she
loves RMB and she has like a series of
moves where she that she just lets hurt
her hips take her away huh and she loves
to Jersey Turnpike I don't know that
what is that it's have you not seen the
do's do you all know that I'll do it for
you but can I get a beat
[Applause]
Stoney throughout Wow yeah that's
amazing that's body takes her away man
she travels when she dances I can't
explain it that's a risky thing to do on
a dance floor I think but but that's
impressive that she does that yeah we
both do it with her because she starts
it and I think it started because she
didn't have a ton of balance right and
then now we've encouraged it and that's
like a go-to move that's probably how it
started with a lot of dancers they just
were drunk and they ended up on the
ground and they're let's call it the
Jersey Turnpike let's make this a move
yeah thank you good night here all week
try the veal
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because hot rod 52 asked
me to if there's something you'd like me
to cover in a future top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video what
lesson really hit home the hardest what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shot at two jennifer
price thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one-word take that
awesome picture posted online I
appreciate your support and also doing a
lot of the research and the interviews
for the book as well I really appreciate
it and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
how did you aim for the career you have
and go get it
well it wasn't it wasn't like first of
all it wasn't like I was spotted in an
airport like you need to be an actress
cuz first of all that never happens
that's like such a myth but it also it
wasn't that much of a like an epiphany
like I've got to do this but it was
honestly more of like a slow burn of of
my enjoyment taking hold of my career I
was sort of always too petite to play
sports and I got involved with well I
sang from a very young age so I loved
music so I was training up radically and
then I was given musical theater as like
after-school homework and I was like
what is musical theater I loved it so
much and then when I was 16 I went into
my guidance counselor's office and they
said okay well let's pick a career that
you would want to study and I was like
what are my options and he he said what
are what do you like I said I love
theater he said oh you can study theater
and I was like great thank you so much
and then I just left and it was like a
it wasn't it just seemed like a natural
progression I sort of like to let things
bloom and follow my instincts and that's
and and somehow just with determination
and ability to handle rejection well it
was there like a lot of when I started
out working as an actress I I was really
intent on being a real actress and I
wanted parts where I can sob and have
heart-wrenching scenes and the older I
get the more I realized how important
plenty is and how much people need to
laugh I think the secret to being funny
is you really just have to be able to
humiliate yourself if you have no rules
and no boundaries chances are you're
going to be pretty funny find what makes
you unique because if you can be unique
and be yourself you are irreplaceable
but the minute you start to fall in line
you're a dime a dozen the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]